alright guys so a lot of people have
sent me a few news articles about
something that recently took place a lot
of people have asked me this a lot of
people and I feel like I have to address
it only God forgives recently premiered
at the Cannes Film Festival in France
now this movie is the follow-up to drive
my favorite movie of 2011 that movie
starred Ryan Gosling it was directed by
Nicolas Winding reppin only God forgives
isn't a sequel or anything but it is the
exact same two people coming together
again to make another movie so thus I
was very excited about it and still am
but at its premiere at the Cannes Film
Festival it was greeted by many walkouts
and booing at the end of the film which
is very sad now before I get into my
thoughts on this let me first express
that that Film Festival has a bit of a
reputation for doing things like this
inglourious basterds was booed and
panned when it was shown at the Cannes
Film Festival for the first time as was
taxi driver and Tree of Life a lot of
different movies that people consider
actually really good weren't exactly
well received at their first showing at
the festival so in the past the audience
of kin has been known to boo films that
are actually good it has happened before
except the reviews on Rotten Tomatoes at
this time are crushing right now it's at
18% which to me is absolutely shocking
now of course is only a few reviews and
I'm sure that once it's shown at
American cinemas where people who are
used to seeing lots and lots and lots of
explicit violence see it that it'll
probably change up a little bit because
18% seems absurdly low but I will be
honest I have watched a few of the clips
and while some of them look really
interesting and really amazing there are
a few scenes where I was like I don't
know about that that seems a little
that's a little off now before I tell
you guys how I feel about the movie in
general and what my overall thoughts and
expectations for it are I want to just
say something really quick am I the only
one who finds it really immature for a
film festival audience to just start
booing a film when all the people who
made it and who worked on it for a few
years are currently there like don't you
find that a little immature and kind of
childlike like they're just kind of
complaining about oh I'm gonna come but
I didn't like that but I'm gonna I mean
it's just that seems so so childlike to
me like elementary school recess fight
childlike like
really immature like when I went to the
tif Film Festival not one film ever got
booed because that audience was
extremely respectful even the lowdown
dirty horror film I saw called no one
lives which by the way just came out
limited release I didn't review it in my
opinion that was the perfect bad movie
it was so bad that you could watch it
with friends and enjoy it but no it
wasn't a good movie but even that
audience didn't boo that film you know
they were respectful I find it a little
bit disrespectful to just sit there in a
theater and be like this movie did not
meet my requirements in my criteria of
what I expect to see in the cinema today
I will boo this film and the right to
scathing review of it because I am
snooty that was my horrible imitation of
people who went to the Cannes Film
Festival I just think it's kind of
stupid to boo a film if you don't like
if you don't like it okay so walk out
and leave you didn't like it you know
okay
granted I have not seen the film yet
perhaps it is very horrific ly offensive
and overly violent perhaps a little
misogynistic even I don't know I'll have
to see the film but I really don't think
that Ryan Gosling and Nicolas winning
record would come together and go you
know what we're gonna make a
misogynistic woman hating movie because
you know that's what we do I mean
Gosling is like famous for like being in
love with his mother like he just loves
his mom so much these I mean it's just
stupid to even make a comment like that
from what I've heard Gosling has hardly
any lines in the film at all and I'm
sure that people who saw Drive and we're
like Gosling didn't talk enough are
gonna now think about drive that yeah
there was enough dialog and drive after
they see only God forgives I am sure
that the movie will have incredible
cinematography I'm sure that it will be
edited well and I'm sure the soundtrack
by Cliff Martinez will be good it will
more than likely be acted very well
however what I am worried about is the
story and the script and how it's going
to come together and if it really just
comes off as a director essentially
masturbating to himself which is what a
lot of people are saying another comment
I've gotten from a lot of people is that
Christoph and you're just going to love
on the gut forgive so much because
you're such a Nicholas winning referent
fanboy
oh you're you got you're gonna love it
no matter what because you can't make
your own opinion you just want to love
every movie that he makes I'm sorry
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard of my life I've seen almost every
wending referent film and there are a
few that I honestly think are crap like
you ever saw the movie fear X that is
movie with John Turturro directed by
Nicolas winning repin
that started out so promising and then
literally fizzles into nothing it has
no ending it just goes bless it's like
it turns into this existential idiocy
and Nikolas winning wrecking was trying
to take a chance on that movie to do
something a little different and it
really did not pay off at all I really
like Bronson even in Valhalla rising
despite the fact that it really doesn't
have much of a story and still has that
same like emotionless hero with no words
that Nikolas winning reference seems to
really like it was a well-made film it
was intriguing but it wasn't really
anything special drive is really the
only movie of his that I flat-out loved
and so I am excited for only God
forgives but I'm telling you guys if
it's not good I'll be honest with you
I'll tell you I mean I wanted to love
diehard 5 and how much did that suck and
I was honest about it so basically my
thoughts on the film being booed is that
it happens before we have to wait and
see what other audiences think of it
because a lot of the type of audience
and the critics that go to the Cannes
Film Festival are notoriously picky but
really the thing that does worry me is
that the Cannes Film Festival did give
Nicholas winning rough and the Best
Director award for a drive when it
premiered so that's saying something see
from what I've learned about winning
ruffed and studying him because he is
definitely a very inspiring director to
me he has a thing where when he obtains
any success he feels as if he must then
kind of change and do something
different which is completely normal and
very admirable but what I mean by that
is he really feels like he has to then
not just change but he asked her like
throw everyone on their head and do
something totally different and it has
caused some serious problems for his
career in the past his company basically
just died because of fear X he tried to
do something so different and it didn't
work out I am excited to see the movie
because I know that as a director he's
interested in creating art and things
that are different but I do want to see
this film for myself I know that this
reaction from can is a little shocking
to me and most people but I am excited
to see what the film is like and of
course tell you guys if it ain't good
but I'll tell you if it is good in my
opinion too and I'll give you reasons
why thanks for watching guys and if you
like this review you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes